I coach many CEOs around the world and
some are embracing this and creating
their own social media strategies as CEO
and others you know don't even know what
social media is yet and don't have a
personal strategy and aren't doing
anything as it relates to that and I
think you know my message to CEOs is not
every CEO needs to be out tweeting every
day about you know they're going to
starbucks now or they're in best buy but
what they do need to do is have a social
media strategy for their company and
depending on what company they are for
example if you look in the technology
space you know Eric Schmidt at Google he
tweets you know Brian done at Best Buy
he tweets I mean because the industry
that they're in they need to be savvy
and they need to be a forward-looking
company as it relates to sort of
connecting with their broader
constituency who typically are very
technology savvy it makes sense but it
doesn't make sense for every CEO to to
have a Twitter account and be out there
messaging but what does make sense is
CEOs need to figure out what the right
way for them to have a two-way dialogue
with the broader constituencies that
impact their company and that can be a
blog it can be tweeting it can be you
know these sorts of videos that go up on
the web but they need to come up with a
strategy for their company and for
themselves that allows them to have a
two-way dialogue it's going to happen
whether you like it or not it's not the
old world where you as a CEO message to
your constituencies and they say oh
that's great or they don't read it or
they read it today it's you have to have
a discussion with everybody and that
discussions often in real time and you
need to be part of it so I think it's
important for CEOs to figure out how
they're going to engage in that dialogue
and what their strategy for them
personally as a CEO is going to be and
then what the strategy is going to be
for their company
last week or the week before Alan Joyce
who's the CEO of Qantas wrote an article
in The Wall Street Journal was
interviewed in the Wall Street Journal
and what he said that he underestimated
when he was dealing with the crisis of
the a380 engine was the social aspects
of of the media part of his campaign in
terms of touching the broader
constituencies so the Qantas crisis was
Qantas flies this new super jumbo jet
called the a380 double-decker it's the
greatest biggest airplane you've ever
seen in your life I've flown it many
times and loved it what happened was is
one of their planes was flying out of
Singapore and the engine blew up and
they had to do an emergency landing and
everything was safe and they landed the
plane and everything was good but coming
out of that obviously Qantas grounded
their entire a380 fleet and the CEO of
Qantas had to reestablish a canary
establish a connection with the broader
constituencies everybody who flies in
airplanes a and then be everybody who
flies on Qantas airplanes and then sort
of reestablish this connection with them
that everything is going to be okay
we're handling this here are all the
safety protocols that were going through
rolls-royce who make the engine were in
deep discussions with them and we're not
going to put them in the air again until
they're safe and by the way when the
first one flies I'm going to be on it
right that's what the CEO did and he was
on it what he said in the article though
is he missed the opportunity through
social media Twitter blogs every social
media outlet to really touch in
real-time the broader constituencies and
he said his learning was if I'm ever in
a crisis like that again I'm going to
really take that seriously so I can
touch people so they know what's going
on personally they don't have to wait
for a press release the other one you
know that everybody is read about
obviously is in the oil and gas industry
and i think the the company
underestimated sort of you know how much
connective tissue you needed to have
with the impacted areas from an oil
spill and how you deal with people in
real time and how it's not good enough
to put your message
is out but you have to be there you know
in the flesh and taking the hits right
and if you're unwilling to do that it's
at your peril because not a you know
you're going to fall and somebody else
is going to stand up who's willing to go
in and take the hits and really engage
people in this dialogue both
face-to-face and through every other
medium and that's just the world we live
in today you have to get out and touch
people